afternoon and welcome to the ECB press
conference I'm joined here on stage by
President Lagarde
and by vice president de guindos
my name is Wolfgang cloison as always
this is a hybrid press conference so for
the online participants I would ask them
to turn on their camera and their
microphones if they wish to ask
questions and with that I turn over to
president Lagarde please thank you very
much and good afternoon
the vice president and I welcome you to
our press conference
the inflation Outlook continues to be
too high and for too long
in light of the
ongoing High inflation pressures the
governing Council today decided to raise
the three key ECB interest rates by 25
basis points
overall the incoming information broadly
supports the assessment of the
medium-term inflation Outlook that we
formed at our previous meeting
headline inflation has declined over
recent months but underlying price
pressures remain strong
at the same time our past rate increases
are being transmitted forcefully to Euro
area financing and monetary conditions
with the lags and strength of
transmission to the real economy remain
uncertain
our future decisions will ensure that
the policy rates will be brought to
levels sufficiently restrictive
to achieve a timely return of inflation
to our two percent medium-term Target
and will be kept at those levels for as
long as necessary
we will continue to follow a data
dependent approach to determining the
appropriate level and duration of
restrictions
in particular our policy rate decisions
will continue to be based on our
assessment of the inflation Outlook in
light of the incoming economic and
financial data
the Dynamics of underlying inflation and
the strength of monetary policy
transmission
the key ECB interest rates remain our
primary tool for setting the monetary
policy stance
in parallel we will keep reducing the
Euro systems asset purchase program
portfolio
at a measured and predictable pace
in line with these principles the
governing Council expects to discontinue
the reinvestments under the app as of
July 2023
the decisions taken today are set out in
a press release that is available on our
website
and I will now outline in more details
how we see the economy and inflation
developing
and will then explain our assessment of
Financial and monetary conditions
looking at the economic activity
the Euro area economy grew by 0.1
percent in the first quarter of 23
according to eurostat preliminary flash
estimate
lower energy prices the easing of supply
bottlenecks and fiscal policy support
for firms and households have
contributed to the resilience of the
economy
at the same time
private domestic demand specially
consumption is likely to have remained
weak
business and consumer confidence have
recovered steadily in recent months but
remain weaker than before Russia's
unjustified war against Ukraine and its
people
we see a Divergence across sectors of
the economy
the manufacturing sector is working
through a backlog of orders
but its prospects are worsening
the services sector is growing more
strongly
especially owing to the reopening of the
economy
household incomes are benefiting from
the strength of the labor market
with the unemployment rate falling to a
new historical low of 6.5 percent in
March
employment has continued to grow and
total hours worked exceed pre-pandemic
levels
at the same time the average number of
hours worked remains somewhat below its
pre-pandemic level
and its recovery has stalled since
mid-2022.
as the energy crisis fades
governments should
roll back the related support measures
promptly and in a concerted manner to
avoid driving up medium-term
inflationary pressures which would call
for a stronger monetary policy response
fiscal policies should be oriented
towards making our economy more
productive and gradually bringing down
high public debt
policies to enhance the Euro area's
Supply capacity especially in the energy
sector can also help reduce price
pressures in the medium term
in this regard we welcome the
publication of the European commission's
legislative proposals for the reform of
the eu's economic governance framework
which should be concluded soon
turning now to inflation
according to eurostat's flush estimate
inflation was at seven percent in April
after having dropped from 8.5 percent in
February down to 6.9 percent in March
while basis effects led to some increase
in energy price inflation from 0. minus
0.9 percent in March to plus 2.5 percent
in April
the rate stands far below those recorded
after the start of Russia's war against
Ukraine
food price inflation remains elevated
however
standing at 13.6 percent in April after
15.5 percent in March
price pressures remain strong
inflation excluding energy and food was
5.6 in April having edged down slightly
compared with march to return to its
February level
non-energy industrial goods inflation
fell to 6.2 percent in April from 6.6
percent in March when it declined for
the first time in several months
but Services inflation increased to 5.2
percent in April from 5.1 percent in
March
inflation is still being pushed up by
the gradual pass-through of past energy
cost increases and supply bottlenecks
in Services especially it is still being
pushed higher also by pent-up demand
from the reopening of the economy and by
Rising wages
the information available up to March
suggests that indicators of underlying
inflation remain high
weight pressures have strengthened
further as employees in the context of a
robust labor market recoup some of the
purchasing power they have lost as a
result of high inflation
moreover in some sectors
firms have been able to increase their
profit margins on the back of mismatches
between supply and demand and the
uncertainty created by high and volatile
inflation
although most measures of longer-term
inflation expectations currently stand
at around two percent
some indicators have edged up and
warrant continued monitoring
let us now look at our risk assessment
renewed Financial Market tensions if
persistent would pose a downside risk to
the outlook for growth as they could
tighten broader credit conditions more
strongly than expected and dampen
confidence
Russia's war against Ukraine also
continues to be a significant downside
risk to the economy
however the recent reversal of past
adverse Supply shocks if sustained
could spur confidence and support higher
growth than currently expected
the continued resilience of the labor
market
by bolstering household confidence and
spending could also lead to higher
growth than anticipated
there are still significant upside risks
to the inflation Outlook
these include existing pipeline
pressures that could send retail prices
higher than expected in the near term
moreover Russia's war against Ukraine
could again push up the costs of energy
and food
a lasting rise in inflation expectations
above our Target are higher than
anticipated increases in wages or profit
margins could also Drive inflation
higher including over the medium term
recent negotiated wage agreements have
added to the upside risks to inflation
especially if profit margins remain high
the downside risks include renewed
Financial Market tensions which could
bring inflation down faster than
projected
weaker demand due for example to a more
marked slowing of Bank Lending
or a stronger transmission of monetary
policy would also lead to lower price
pressures than currently anticipated
especially over the medium term
so let's look at the financial and
monetary conditions
the Euro area banking sector has proved
resilient in the face of the financial
Market tensions that arose ahead of our
last meeting
our policy rate increases are being
transmitted strongly to risk-free
interest rates and to the financing
conditions for firms households and
Banks
for firms and households
loan growth has weakened owing to higher
borrowing rates
tighter credit Supply conditions and
lower demand
our latest Bank lending survey reported
a tightening of overall credit standards
which was stronger than Banks had
expected in the previous round and
suggest that lending May weaken further
weak Landing has meant that money growth
has also continued to decline
summing up the inflation Outlook
continues to be too high for too long
in light of the ongoing High inflation
pressures the governing Council today
decided to raise the three key ECB
interest rates by 25 basis points
overall the incoming information broadly
supports the assessment of the
medium-term inflation Outlook that we
formed at our previous meeting
headline inflation has declined over a
recent month but the underlying price
pressures remain strong
at the same time our past rate increases
are being transmitted forcefully to Euro
area financing and monetary conditions
while the lag and strength of
transmission to the real economy remain
uncertain
our future decisions will ensure that
the policy rates will be brought to
levels sufficiently restrictive to
achieve a timely return of inflation to
our two percent medium-term Target and
will be kept at those levels for as long
as necessary
we will continue to follow a data
dependent approach to determining the
appropriate level and duration of
restriction
in particular our policy rate decisions
will continue to be based on our
assessment of the inflation Outlook in
light of the incoming economic and
financial data
the Dynamics of underlying inflation and
the strength of monetary policy
transmission
in any case we stand ready to adjust all
of our instruments within our mandate to
ensure that inflation returns to our
medium-term Target
and to preserve the smooth functioning
of monetary policy transmission
we are now ready to take your questions
thank you president Lagarde and the
first question goes to another device
bar from CNBC another please
thank you very much president lagardev
of course two questions my first
question would be on the rationale
behind the reduced Pace In the interest
rate hike of 25 basis points so why did
you come up with that
um and my second question goes to the
U.S Regional anchor lender banking
crisis which isn't over yet so um How
concerned are you about potential
spillover effects to the euro area thank
you
well thank you for your question I will
take the first and maybe I will ask my
my colleague and friend vice president
who's the guindos to address the uh the
second one
so let me tell you a little bit about
the mood in the in the room of the
governing Council
um I would characterize the mood as
determined
all governors are determined to
fight inflation tame inflation and
return it to two percent medium term
and we all concluded as you have seen
that the inflation Outlook is too high
and has been so for too long
I would say then that the mood was very
focused and yet it is an in-between
projection governing council meeting but
we were extremely attentive to all data
that was available to us and obviously
one case in point is the bank lending
survey that you all received also on
Tuesday when it was published and which
contains a lot of intelligence and
information about the intention and the
comparison between the lending practices
and standards with what was expected by
the Banks and I'm happy to come back to
that later but it explains obviously the
decision that we made for this 25 basis
point increase
I think in terms of method uh we were
method dependent in many way just as we
are data dependent because we have
articulated the reaction function of our
monetary policy decisions with the three
key elements of the inflation Outlook
informed by the financial and economic
data the underlying inflation and the
strength of monetary policy transmission
so we checked all the data that we had
against this three criterias
and as is always the case at the
governing council meeting there was a
variety of views expressed
and I think that it's fair to say that
everybody agreed that
increasing rate was necessary
that uh second we are not posing
that very clear
third we know that we have more grounds
to cover
on the basis of the Baseline that we had
which is still guiding us until we have
our next projection exercise
and on the basis of the data
that we have received in the course of
the last few days and that we brought
together during the meeting
so
I think the uh ultimate Balancing Act
which received almost unanimous support
and that is reflected in the monetary
policy statement in front of you was
really predicated on the methods the
data we received the understanding that
where we are is totally consistent with
the Baseline that we had for the Outlook
last time around remember at the last
March meeting that's what I said
and second that underlying inflation is
still
High
and third informed by the bank lending
survey and the data that we have
concerning interest rates which is a
little bit outdated because it goes back
to February the transmission of our
monetary policy is working at least to
the financing leg
and we're not yet certain about the next
language is transmission from Banks to
the real economy so it's on the basis of
all that that we made our decision
you know now that we have you know
increased rates significantly and
sometimes by very large increments uh I
hope assessing
um
not assessing but establishing absolute
credibility on our determination it was
sensible in view of what I have told you
to return to a more standard increment
with the understanding that based on the
information we have today we have more
ground to cover and we are not pausing
that's extremely clear
good afternoon turning to your second
question
I think that we should start by a
consideration if you look at the
characteristics of the of the U.S banks
that are run into difficulties
I think that there are some common
features the first one is that they are
medium-sized Regional
they share a very concrete and very
idiosyncratic business model and they
are quite open to interest rate risks
they are vulnerable to an increase in in
jills
and I think that you know this model
this situation is not extrapolatable
today uh to the to the European banking
banking industry well I will not repeat
what we have said many times European
banks are resilient the level of capital
the level of liquidity the quality of
the of the liquid assets but I think
that simultaneously we have to remember
that an increase in interest rates in
yields is positive for the European
Banks because the increase
in in margins outweighs the potential
losses that this increase in jail good
costs in fixing on portfolios
but I think that is quite clear that
there is no there is no space for
complacency uh one of the things that we
have uh we have been all of us surprised
is about uh you know how rapidly a bank
run can take place and how rapidly
a bank and I think that this is the
combination of new factors the first one
is digital Banking and the second one is
social networks and the combination of
both have even right to and have even
rise to a new situation and I think that
supervisors and Regulators we have to to
bear in mind that new framework because
we believe that you know this is going
to begin the near future
thank you president vice president the
next question goes to Francesco canepa
of Reuters Francesco please
Reuters so my first question is about
whether anyone at the meeting
um insisted on this on a larger rate
hike or on a clearer commitment to more
hikes you just hinted at that by talking
about ground to cover but it wasn't
quite as explicit as it was back in the
winter when you were talking about
steady pace and several rate hikes
second question is about something you
just said which is again that you had
more ground to cover would you say that
we are still in the middle of the
journey or towards the end in the home
stretch thank you
I'm tempted to remind you of the Amazon
quote
it's not so much the destination that
matters but the journey and we are on a
journey
okay and we are not posing
and under present circumstances and
based on what we have which is the
Baseline of March we know that we have
more ground to cover
okay and there is a there is a clear
reference to that if you look carefully
and I know you have because you do that
very well but in the second paragraph of
the monetary policy statement we
explicitly refer to that by saying that
our future decisions will ensure that
the policy rates will be brought to
levels sufficiently restrictive to
achieve a timely return of inflation to
our two percent medium term Target and
will be kept at those levels for as long
as necessary
we have covered a lot of ground in the
last nine months Right Moving from minus
50 basis points to plus 300 basis points
We are continuing this hiking process as
I said this is a journey
we have not arrived yet
as to you know the uh the exact amount
of you know by how much do we increase
rates as I said in my introduction uh in
the response to the first questions
there was a variety of views
some governors
suggested that maybe 50 was appropriate
others
also believe that 25 was appropriate I
didn't hear anybody suggest that zero
would be appropriate so that confirms to
you that this is this is a hiking
Journey that we are on and and it it
will it will continue to be so but at
the end of the deliberations and having
had a chance to confront our views and
to you know answer the questions and and
to really sort of put everything in
perspective there was a general very
strong consensus behind the decision
that you have in front of you
thank you madam regards and the next
question is
Bloomberg News
um I would like to invite you uh to
elaborate a little bit more on your
definition of sufficiently restrictive
um the IMF had a view um the other day
um seeing the terminal rate at 3.75 a
lot of economists do that as well would
that be something given the inflation
Outlook we we have at the moment that
that would be in the ballpark of of
sufficiently restrictive the other
question I have is um that at the last
meeting you had a little bit of a debate
about over tightening and having to
reverse course and I'm wondering whether
that discussion um continued this time
and whether you would actually be
worried that that such a scenario might
be interpreted as a policy mistake
thank you
well thank you thank you very much the
um
I I don't have a magic number of what
constitutes
open quote
um sufficiently restrictive end of quote
I think that the the honest answer is
we will know what that is when we get
there and we are in the process
of moving in that direction
I think what's important is to
understand you know what what what it
means to have restrictive uh rates and
to be in restrictive territory and I
think the best example is to see whether
the rate decisions that we make the rate
increases that we decide are actually
having an impact on the economic actors
and when when we look at the bank
lending survey in particular or when we
look at the uh the interest rates and
and the pace at which it has increased
in the last few months it is obviously
the fact that interest rate decisions
that we made and the interest rates
level where we are are having an effect
is it a sufficient effect yet
we don't know
because
we are not seeing the transmission at
this point in time into this what I call
the second leg of the economy which is
the the real activity which then has an
impact on on on prices and then reduces
inflation so full cycle we're not seeing
yet we're seeing inflation coming down
don't get me wrong because headline is
coming down uh as a result of energy
prices having have been coming down
significantly as a result of the easing
of of bottlenecks but when we're not yet
seeing the complete impacts that we
desire in order to arrive at the two
percent medium term uh that that
constitutes our Target we will we will
we are very attentive we look at that as
you know it's one of the three
components that we look at the inflation
Outlook but we we are it is restrictive
no question about it is it sufficiently
restrictive not yet
thank you thank you president Lagarde
and the next question goes to Martin
Arnold of the financial times Martin
please
thank you uh hello president legard I
have two questions for you the first one
is on the decision to accelerate the
pace of shrinking the bond portfolio of
the ECB
um does that mean now that you're
stopping all reinvestments in the app
does that mean that you plan to reduce
the app to zero eventually
um and the second question that I have
is was this decision part of a
compromise deal uh to uh convince those
arguing for a 50 basis point move to
accept a 25 basis point move in return
for accelerating the pace of shrinking
your balance sheet thank you
oh thank you very much Martin for the
for this sort of double question
um on on the same issue of the app
well I would say number one we made the
decision but the decision specifically
says we expect so
we expect
to let the app runoff
as time goes by and in answer to your
question about do we go to zero if we do
then it's going to take the next 15
years so I don't think I'll be around
for that I know I won't and I'm not sure
that you will be around but the ultimate
perspective is is is that one as we
consider things uh today
um
you know we've decided to to
expect the effectiveness of that
decision as of July saving a little bit
of optionalities just in case simply
because we
have seen that the partial reinvestment
that we decided back in that has been
effective since March has actually run
very smoothly and has been well absorbed
by markets so we don't see any any point
in in not accelerating the move because
there are valid reason for that you know
lower the amount of excess liquidity
complements our policy rate increases
reduce the side effect of a large
balance sheets or all of that completely
justifies the fact that the app is led
to run off gradually over the course of
time which will be an average
um an average 25 billion per month not
reinvested roughly but as I said to to
run the whole app program to zero it
will take 12 to 15 years
um given the maturities of what we have
I would just reserve one thing because
we discussed it during the governing
Council and it's not reflected in the uh
in the monetary policy statement as you
know we have adopted a tilting approach
to our investment policy of the app and
in particular for the corporate bonds
which are the prime uh Prime targets of
that tilting in order to privilege those
corporates that have a good
environmental footprint that have a
transition plan and
that disclose all the appropriate
information about their plans now of
course if we if we go to full runoff
that tilting process is not going to be
applicable because there will be nothing
to tilt It Off
um there will be no basis for that so I
think the jury is out as to how we can
continue to deliver on our Paris
agreement compliant investment
reinvestment program without the
reinvestment phase and and how do we do
we address that which is something that
we agreed we would we would take into
account and consider to see how we will
respond to that was it was it a deal no
no I we
um I think there was there was a general
view that that was the right uh the
right move completely sense you know
sensible legitimate at this point in
time given the market absorption I think
some might have preferred to wait until
um the June meeting to announce it given
that its effectiveness of the first of
July but you know with the principle of
predictability that we had agreed in the
first place we thought it was just
better off to just announce it with
reserving a little optionality on the
side
thank you president Lagarde and the next
question goes to oldcastlec of bfmtv
French television
is there a Target for Bank Landing or
limits in accreditation how do you
monitor these indicators and second
question you said recently in relation
to bank failures on the credius risk
case that you really need to measure
what comes out of this financial event
so what are the indicators that you're
looking at would you say that there is a
bunking crisis what's your view of
what's happening there in the banking
system
thank you
yeah on the on the you know we we know
of one and only one Target and this is
our medium term Target two percent that
that's that's what is is riveting our
attention but of course the bank lending
survey that that we receive on it on a
quarterly basis informs us about the the
tightening of credit to the economy
and it also informs us about what the
banks assess will be or will not be the
tightening and it's quite a
sophisticated uh survey which which is
really for uh information intelligence
anticipation of the of the credit uh
tightening now and the credit tightening
going forward it's also illustrative of
the demand and that's that's an
interesting point because in the BLS
the demand from corporates is really
really down so that's you know learning
that we take which indicates that our
interest rate policies is beginning to
have an impact because when asked the
corporates say and we had the corporate
survey that was conducted they say
it's the interest rates
it's not that you know we don't want to
invest but the interest rates are are
pretty high and that leads me to the
restrictive territory or not yes we are
in restrictive territory because if that
is the response of corporates then then
shows that this work
you know on on Credit Suisse I think
I'll also a few words and then I'll I'll
ask my my colleague Mr de guindos to
also address that but
number one it was addressed very swiftly
the Swiss authorities maybe did not have
many choices
and it was very specific and probably a
long lasting issue that was lingering
and had been lingering for a long time
so I certainly would not draw the
conclusion that the merger between UBS
and Credit Suisse to be decided is an
indication that there is a financial
crisis far from it but we are learning I
think that we also learned the value of
having rules and the ability we had to
come out very quickly on
on the pecking order of creditors
actually mattered a lot and I think that
we we can also take a bit of learning
from that when when creditors investors
know exactly who is going to Bear the
brunt of
um outstanding liabilities and a
situation of of insolvency it it just
helps and we did that I'm glad we did
well yes to that that on the on the on
the question about the indicators that
we we consider that we look at well we
have a range of indicators for instance
you know Equity prices
Bank won the spreads the evolution of
deposits and we have not seen you know
the kind of situations that happened in
other in other jurisdictions so we had
let's say a sort of you know increase of
tensions after you know the events in
the US with Silicon Valley and with
groceries and afterwards you know the
situation has been quite quite calm so
we are continuously looking at those
indicators but uh well you know clearly
now you know the conclusion is that the
European banking industry has been
clearly performing the American one in
terms of detention you know included in
this kind of indicators and you know the
potential stress in financial markets
thank you vice president president and
uh turning to our online participants
now
um I would like to give the floor to
Francesco nilfoyle of Milano finanza
Francesco please
thank you good afternoon president
can you explain a little bit more how
you reconcile your data dependency with
the pledge
Excuse excuse us can you repeat because
we did we missed a bit a few questions
okay can I explain what okay can you
explain how you reconcile your data
dependency with the
pledge of doing more in the future it
can be a little bit contradictory like a
forward guidance without a forward
guidance maybe you explain you can
explain it a little bit more secondly on
a core inflation
no doubt it is important to monitor core
inflation but the ECB is targeted as you
have said now just now is headline
inflation at two percent in the medium
term
so how do you explain such a great
emphasis on core inflation also given
also considering that core inflation has
not been a good leading indicator for
Headland inflation in the past thank you
thank you very much
um
data dependency is not forward guidance
and I'll try to explain that for you for
a second
I'm not giving you the forward guidance
that come what may or subject to or
until such time we will do this or that
that for me would be for guidance okay
and we had it in the past and it was
very appropriate to have forward
guidance as we were at the lower bound
and that was a tool that was very useful
what I'm telling you now is
given our Baseline
the findings that we have the data that
we can analyze today
our judgment in the room
is that
we are not posing that applies to today
and based on what we see we determine
that we have more ground to cover
I'm not saying that in the abstract I'm
saying that with reference to the
Baseline of March to what we are seeing
in development and I'm here saying
we believe that we have more ground to
cover it is not State dependent it is
not time dependent it is a judgment that
we make today so I hope I've been clear
to try to explain to you how we can
actually say that
very firmly without giving forward
guidance and being data dependent comes
the June meeting comes the July meeting
comes the September meeting and so on
and so forth
we will look at the data
and we will use the three criteria of
our
reaction function for monetary policy
purposes and we will make our decision
on a meeting by meeting basis so
you've also asked me another question
about core
we had long discussions about core and
we actually had many more discussions
on underlying inflation because core is
interesting core core is easy to
communicate
you take headline the whole basket of
everything that's in the index you take
out food you take out
anything having to do with energy and
you have core
but we want to go a little bit deeper
into into the the the index and the
evolution that we see and we have
multiple measurements that you are
familiar with
um you know the trim the pcci the pcci
excluding energy and so on and so forth
we look at all of those and we try to
understand from the evolution that we
see what is the likelihood of inflation
evolution
so
I'm not maybe addressing you core versus
headline but simply I'm saying that
headline is the objective that we have
it's the Target that we have that we've
agreed in our strategy review it's also
it happens to be what matters to people
see all prices increasing
and we're working for the people of
Europe okay
core
easy to communicate but maybe not as
informative as we want it to be so that
leads us to dissect in far more details
inflation thank you
thank you president Lagarde and the next
question goes to Christian zeden Beadle
of Frankfort arguments Christian please
yes thank you madam I'm sure many
pinterested to know whether the worst of
inflation is over for food
do you have that impression
thank you for that question because it
is it is food prices that is hurting
most uh particularly the most vulnerable
people and we know that because the in
in the basket of consumption the most
vulnerable spend a lot more on food than
those who are well off so we we pay
special attention of course to uh to
food
and and the increase in prices
we have seen it go down right if you
compare March and April numbers so it is
going down
but we have to be extremely attentive
because there are multiple factors that
apply to food prices that apply to
processed food prices I think we have
also
um
flagged the fact that
profit last year in particular in 2022
have contributed to inflation this year
23 what we have seen of 23 we see more
wage increases contributing to inflation
we would hope that through an a good
social contract
the these drivers of inflation
do not
activate each other in what I have
called in other places a Tit for Tat you
know I want more wages I'm not going to
give up on profits and and you you are
then at risk of of something that is uh
much more difficult and would lead us to
have to take more active measures in
monetary policy
so I wish I could tell you of course it
will continue to go down
but I've I'm observing that it has gone
down there are the factors that will
come into play you know clearly climate
change is something that will have an
impact probably on a sectoral basis
probably in relation to certain food
items uh what happens in Ukraine is also
going to bring another uncertainty in
the background of Serial price in
particular but commodity prices have
gone down that is that is a fact so
hopefully it it will channel to the
ultimate consumer
thank you madam nagar and the next
question goes to Android for expansion
Andres please
can the ACB continue hiking If the Fed
stops is that a baseline scenario you're
working on and a second question uh do
you have any estimates on how much
tightening is the QT and the tltro
maturity adding to the monetary policy
stance can you can perhaps phrase it in
in hiking or basis points of hikes thank
you
um you know I've heard the fiscal
dependency I've heard the finance
dependency I had not heard the FED
dependency so the ECB is an independent
Central Bank you know looks at what
others do around the world from New
Zealand which has been an interesting
innovator in the field of monetary
policy all the way to the fed and and
and and and others and it's obvious that
the U.S economy in whichever way it
evolves has spillover effect around the
world given of its given its size the
depth of its financial markets but you
know we we have a Target we have a
journey we know as of today that we have
more ground to cover and whatever the
decision of the FED is in the next few
weeks months we are going to be riveted
to our objective and we'll of course
take into account
variables you know the the currency for
instance has an impact the uh the any
spillovers will be taken into account
but we are not
fed dependent in in in that respect as
to the the actual tightening impact
[Music]
that the app runoff has I don't want to
to commit a number but it does not have
a massive impact suffice to say but we
can give you you know separately the
exact amount that has been calculated
but it's not it's not Material
thank you and the next question goes to
Anna Charisma of the Finnish television
Ule
hello and thank you for the opportunity
and nice to see you again we met in
Lapland so yeah you you have repeated
that uh the journey continues and you
are not pausing uh there are many
households in in Finland Lithuania Spain
that uh struggle with the much higher
interest rates and have had to cut down
on their spending so uh how do you take
them into account when hiking the
interest rates and then a second one
what should they prepare themselves for
what can you say to them about the
future when can we see the policy rates
uh going down and maybe affecting also
the 12-month Euro
thank you well thank you so much and
it's nice to see you again in in warmer
circumstances
um so of course we are aware of these uh
these households that have contracted uh
loans with floating rates variable rates
whatever you call it uh and from from
Finland to uh to Portugal from some of
the Baltic countries to Spain it is the
case that some families are are hurting
because the reimbursements that they
have to honor have gone I've gone up as
a result of the interest rate increases
that we had to decide
this is unfortunately not something that
we can you know alleviate or or
attenuate because I'll
task is price stability our task is to
reduce inflation and the tools of choice
that works in that respect is the
interest rates and we have to use that
that interest rate some countries are
taking particular steps and measures and
some financial institutions are also
looking at offering moratorium or delay
and I think that the best we can do is
to really tame inflation in a timely
manner meaning as fast as we can in
order to then
facilitate a return to uh two different
interest rates that would not be as high
in the future and I'm not here making
any commitment to cut at any point in
time thank you very much
thank you president regards and the next
question goes to shogo akagawa of Nikkei
Japanese newswire here in the middle
thank you you will travel next week to
Japan for G7 meeting what can what kind
of topics do you want to bring at this
upcoming meeting from European point of
view thank you
thank you for giving us that that angle
from from the East
um you know I would hope that together
with my European colleagues uh we can
one learn from colleagues particularly
Japan which is which has just now uh
which is moving into a new Direction
with a new governor so anything that
will be the Japanese monetary policy
going forward and any understanding that
we have of their strategy review which
he has announced I will be of interest
and I would be very happy to share with
him the learnings from our strategy
review which I had started when I took
the job
I would also hope that we can explain
two colleagues from Canada Japan and the
United States that the Europeans
together
are going to continue to demonstrate
resilience
capacity to operate together
and I would hope that in that respect
something that we say in a statement
here will resonate which is to agree on
the fiscal governance in short order so
that in addition to having a monetary
policy that is common to 20 countries we
also have a fiscal framework
which gives governance to the 27 member
states
and that fiscal policies that are
determined by member states are also
focused on value for money for lack of a
better word in other words putting in
place the right reforms
focusing the spending where it is going
to increase the the competitiveness and
and the efficiency of the economy which
is something that is absolutely
indispensable in order to have this
social contract which is often
associated with Europe
thank you thank you Madame laga and the
next question goes to Isabel agufaki of
his soul Adventure Isabella please
good afternoon
opportunity if I may go back to a
quantitative tightening just to
understand whether there is more ground
to cover on qt or whether with this um
end of our investments on app this is
the end of QT there could be more to be
done with pep for example starting on
pandemic or selding bonds to make it
even quicker so this also helps to
understand how important is QT as a
restrictive tool monetary policy and my
second question if I may is on taltros
because even if the European banking
system is solid and resilient and the
banking crisis from the US
could be over we hope still taltres are
going to end in an odd moment and are
you concerned or are you confident the
banks can give back 500 billion in June
and get away with 77 400 about yeah
thank you thank you very much uh on on
QT let me be very clear QT is the
decision that we expect to implement as
of the first of July concerns app
reinvestment only and nothing else
we have forward guidance on on pep
reimbursement nothing until 24. and you
will find I think in the uh in the annex
to my statement reference to the pep and
to the principle of flexibility which we
believe is an important
key aspect of of Pep going forward so
those tools are intact we're not
planning on uh not reinvesting anything
that comes for Redemption under the
under the pep agreement
on the um
on telltro but tell true you know there
is no surprise about teltro huh
um
if anything we have managed to to offer
the possibility for for banks to
accelerate and anticipate the
reimbursement which I think has avoided
a cliff effect that we would have had uh
in in the you know over a trillion
dollars would have become outstanding in
in June thanks to the accelerated
reimbursement we are now down to 477 I'm
checking the numbers because I want to I
want to be clear on that so it's not a
surprise it's a it's a come due date and
reimbursements are due and I know that
banks have prepared for it uh and and
that there is a lot of liquidity out
there to continue to prepare having said
that you know it wouldn't surprise me if
some of the facilities that we have that
are stunning facilities
liquidity windows that are available
full allotment and and and rates that
are well known to to all would become
used usable they are usable and but
would be used again because that's
perfectly normal uh job of a central
bank to actually provide liquidity you
know we have weekly we have the ltro
three months full allotment on on all on
all those liquidity facilities and if if
anything was to happen we have
demonstrated in the past that we can be
inventive
thank you
thank you very much this concludes our
press conference today so I wish you all
the best we have the next press
conference on 15th of June and until
then all the best and a good afternoon
thank you